saved by the bell is a beloved
touchstone for 90s kids everywhere but
for all its wholesome hijinks the show's
set was
more than a little sordid these are the
hookups parties and weirdest fashion
choices that went on behind the scenes
of saved by the bell
you may be surprised to learn that bell
started off as a completely different
show called good morning miss bliss
the pilot episode aired in 1988 starring
hayley mills a british actress as the
titular miss bliss
the show lasted for 13 episodes on the
disney channel before it got cancelled
when miss bliss didn't make it in the
ratings executive producer peter
engel went back to the drawing board the
series was retooled into saved by the
bell
taking four cast members with it mark
paul gossler as zachary zack morris
dustin diamond as samuel screech powers
lark voorhees as lisa turtle and dennis
haskins as
mr belding brian austin green and julia
white also appeared in a scrapped pilot
of miss bliss but did not make the jump
though miss bliss takes place in
indianapolis engel decided to move the
kids to california
he also changed the age range of the
kids on the show from 8th graders to
full-blown high schoolers
saved by the bells beloved zack morris
was inspired
by another high school smart aleck
ferris bueller
as gossler detailed to jimmy fallon he
snagged quite a lot of swagger from that
cinematic slacker
morris's infamous moments of breaking
the fourth wall to speak to the audience
for example are directly inspired by
bueller
oh that was done by ferris bueller yeah
we were just copying him
similarly the character of ac slater was
inspired by vinnie barbarino
the character john travolta made famous
on the 70s sitcom welcome back cotter
first thing you gotta do is vinnie
bobberino look
okay your hair for instance very casual
it should look like it's being blown by
unseen wings
engel recalled slater was supposed to be
vinnie with a leather jacket
italian kid who was a street kid an army
brat
mr belding was also inspired by someone
else but not
in a way the man in question might have
liked the character was named after
richard belding
a pain in the butt editor engel had to
work with at universal
lisa turtle's name came from a real girl
angle new and slater was named after a
friend of angle's son in kindergarten
by the way the ac in ac slater stands
for albert clifford
while gossler diamond haskins and
voorhees all made the move to bell
jenny garth who was up to play kelly
kapowski didn't get the role
she went on to major success however on
beverly hills 90210
which might have been for the best since
not everyone who did get cast and saved
by the bell was thrilled about it
mario lopez initially didn't want to
play slater and admits in his
autobiography he was more interested in
chasing girls than quote trekking up to
la to read for a part that had barely
been sketched out on paper
engel reportedly fought to have tiffany
amber thiessen on the show
knowing she was quote going to be a
major star
elizabeth berkley was also up to play
kelly but wound up playing jesse
a much smarter more evolved character
specifically created for berkeley
as she reflected on bethany she wasn't
super into her wardrobe saying
just because you are a feminist why
can't you also dress in things that make
you feel girly and empowered
as you watch even the most wholesome
family sitcom you just can't help but
wonder
who's hooking up with whom behind the
scenes unsurprisingly putting a bunch of
teenagers together resulted in a whole
lot of romance on the saved by the bell
set
[Applause]
as gossler told people all of us dated
at one point or another it was
incestuous
while much of went on behind the scenes
was innocent some of it became
messy as lopez details in his memoir he
dated thiessen but did not stay faithful
admitting
i can't say that i was capable at that
age of following through on my noble
intentions
there was so much beauty everywhere and
i had so much affection to share
with saved by the bell being full of
teens it's no surprise they did some
partying
thiessen has admitted the first time she
sept alcohol was
with gossler and paris during a press
tour gossler told abc news he did the
time honored showbiz tradition
of using his celebrity to get into adult
clubs at the age of 16
although he insisted but i didn't abuse
it and neither did my cast mates
i can't stress how good we were most of
us probably have regrets about our high
school hair
and the saved by the bell gang is no
exception many fans don't know that
gossler is a natural brunette who had to
bleach his hair blonde for every single
episode
when they sent me the notes on you last
night it said that you dyed your hair
blonde for every single episode i was
like
every day like i can't believe i have
hair now
goslar's hairstyle looked different
every season because surprisingly enough
the bell gang thought every season would
be their last
the show ultimately lasted six years but
as gossler explained
at the end of every season we all left
we said goodbye to each other and that's
why
every season my hairstyle was so
radically different hair drama spared no
one
not even ac slater i didn't even know i
had a mullet it was like an
unintentional mullet elizabeth berkeley
had trouble keeping her wild curly hair
under control and was subjected to
endless procedures treatments and
techniques
the actress recalled they defused my
hair flipped it
teased it sprayed it with hairspray i
practically went through a can of
hairspray a show
one of the most infamous and parodied
saved by the bell episodes is jessie's
song
in it jessie gets hooked on caffeine
pills and finally has a breakdown in
zack's arms as she sings the pointer
sisters hit i'm so excited
i'm so excited i'm so
excited i'm so
scared this moment is widely derided as
cheesy melodramatic and unintentionally
funny
what few know is that this scene was
initially going to be a lot more serious
as angle has detailed jesse was
originally going to be hooked on speed
but nbc standards and practices stepped
in
and told him to tone the episode down
still the point came across
angle said today when i meet fans of the
show jesse's song is almost always the
episode that comes up first
no one was making programming for kids
like that at the time
it made an impact it helped them grow up
and i'm still to this day
proud to have my name on that episode
like so many child stars the bell cast
got screwed by the deal they signed
at the time no one suspected that saved
by the bell would become a huge
phenomena
being young and naive the stars signed
iffy contracts meaning they didn't make
anywhere near as much money as you'd
think you made really bad deals
poor deals back then yeah it is what it
is
and you know you move on you learn
moreover the cast do not make money from
the show syndication nor from its
merchandise
everyone makes mistakes when they're
young but most of us don't have to live
with the knowledge that those mistakes
are still costing us thousands of
dollars every day
dustin diamond fell on hard times after
the show ended
the past few decades have been littered
with scandal and arrests
most infamously he wrote a salacious
tell-all book 2009's behind the bell
its veracity is forcefully disputed by
his former castmates
i'm guessing you have not read that or
i've i've read excerpts
to some degree diamond seems to agree
with their point of view
in recent years he has claimed that his
ghostwriter quote fabricated a whole
bunch of stuff and that he was
railroaded so that's a bummer
but you know what isn't dennis haskins
who played mr belding finally graduated
college in 2015 at the age of 65
earning a bachelor of arts in theater
and speech
for his part haskins looks back fondly
on his time as part of a much beloved tv
classic
saying in 2013 i knew it was something
special because the energy was different
the kids were a little bit older the
dynamic was great between
everybody and we were having a great
time check out one of our newest videos
right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you